που παρουσιάζει και τα οποία δέχεται ένας οκολογικός ασθενής για τρέποια ίναι τα πόσοστα διαγνώσεων
στη χώρα μας οσωστά διαγνώσιων στη χώρα μας ι υπολογίζουμει ότι είναι γύρω στης τα
ράμηση χιλιάδες νέα περιστατικά τ χρόνο το χρόνον δηλαδή να μεγάλον ποοστοιμαείναι όμως περίπου αυτό
το οποίον είναι και ο μέσως ώρος της υπολυπη σεαυρώπης τρα πόσο καλά είναι αυτά
τα στατιστικά στιχία νομίζω ότι αποχρόνως σε χρόνο βελτιώνώνται αλλά κάπου εκι ήμαστεψάχνοντας για να
βρω διάφορα γι αυτό το οτικάς είδα ότι ένας από τους ασθενίς σας έαν οστέλειος
καζανζίτης μεγάλος έλενα στραβοδιστής συμθέτης πως ήταν έκινη περιόδος πόσηρθε κοντά σας πως ιώσατενακινα ήρθε
σε ένα προχωρημένω προωλιμέ στη πολύ προχωρημένο στάδιο και δώσαμε μεγάλες μάχες τάξει ήρθε στη
γερμανία τών εδώσαμε μεγάλες μάχες αι συνδεθήκαμε προσωπικά και με το στέλειο και με τη
κύρια βάσω κύριαβάσω πραγματικά ήταν αξιοθαύμαστε η προσφορά της και συμπαράσταση της στων ανθρωπώ της
τότε ο στέλειος δε είναι ο μήθος που υπάρχει σήμερα τότε σττιωσότανήρθε ήταν στα κάτω
του μετά το θανατόν του άρχισε και οι δύως μετά τώρα την κινημαργοραφική ταινία που
είδαμενόλη δυνοργήθηκε πιο έντερνα ομήθα μετά το θάνατον του το